[Music]
in schools for fools news mmm
I need to go there what that is
submitted by best burgers I love burgers
[Laughter]
I'm all about the Shake Shack stone
you got it shakes I just hope you well
they have a one best burger a couple
years ago in the country best animation
I don't know what my best is that's true
will you go try it I like I like it oh
you tried yeah it's good it's good
I'm not saying I'm not saying it's bad
knee Joe but Shake Shack is better what
are we talking about in choice Shake
Shack I've tried out of it there's no
way you tried and had that reaction I
had girl mom there's one my favorite
yeah I like that she's like a man's
burger I don't know how that if you bite
into it your [ __ ] balls drop like
four inches I don't want that and it
just ginger starts coming out I mean I'm
not a man cuz I don't like that one as
much as shake shake yeah that's too
crazy it's crazy but maybe that's why I
haven't tried shakes I don't know but
when I eat like the pig champion it's
like oh yeah it's too heavy for me I'm
not a minute it's really heavy you like
hot quality ingredients
shake shake we gotta turn it up uncle we
sales host of a hey Dad homeschools is
kid and teaches them about guns and
Bitcoin is crazy
those are the only two subjects period
one a period to know sounds like the
Remo household to me that actually
sounds like you'll be able to make money
and protect your money yeah
well Rob to him that's all you need for
your money guns and Bitcoin yeah not
only that but he teaches his kids about
like the history like for example a
Black Panther movement things like that
so Bitcoin is economics too so that's a
lot of subject right
say they should teach in school how to
invest how to have relationships with
people not sometimes
exactly they don't teach that [ __ ]
because the teachers don't know that
[ __ ] in the first place
guns are scary but they are very very
fascinating how devastating they are
like it is amazing the type of
technologies they've made just not into
the gun itself but the type of bullets
are [ __ ] insane you know what's even
crazier than that the people that know
how to properly use that [ __ ] because
you can have the craziest gun in the
world right travels two miles whatever
no less than like a second and you get
put it in the hands of like one of us
it's not gonna do anything then you get
put that in the hands of like a sniper
and from two miles away they can
accurately take out one eye and then the
other eye and then a nostril and a
nostril that's so that's the great with
wind with wind they tried that in real
life it doesn't work however I do want
this this shotgun cartridge the dragon
breath the thing so it literally shoots
the cartridge whatever beads inside and
also is a flamethrower at the same time
wow that's tiny it explode it is amazing
that's so cool if I were to ever shoot
somebody to death that's the way I'm
gonna do dude is it an instant death
because I'd go out if it was an instant
I mean I'm pretty sure you're gonna be
killed just from whatever the the shell
fragments and then on top of that you're
gonna burn to death so it's pretty want
lasers already like Star Wars
dude that's next level dude you start
searing off body parts that way I
thought I spit all over your own you all
right I was thinking about lasers taking
my arm off like cuz I think I could
handle getting killed but not names I
don't want to get named yeah but you'll
have such cool like stories to tell I
don't wanna [ __ ] warrior I just wanna
be me I always want to be able to dance
like without I just that's and dancing
support if you can't dancing the world's
over exactly what do I have to live for
then yeah so this dad here his name is
Derek he's from Tampa Florida and he has
four kids nine year old a six year old
and two twin baby girls all cute and so
he teaches he took out his nine-year-old
son when he was in first grade out of
public school and he created his own
curriculum at home called unlearn and
relearn it so it's built on four
elements of self love self education
self awareness and self reliance and I
love it I like that anything that these
he believes that these are key to living
mentally free and fruitful life so I'm
gonna show you guys a video like he
could see him how he I'm not gonna put
kids in school [ __ ] that
I am I trying to say she's hella would
have to learn basic math and then that's
good on the math you know I'll work on
you man you got T so you get brainwashed
yeah everything else is just about time
management
yeah I'm social skin self-discipline
yeah alright let's watch this cuz I'm
curious to see what he said my children
we're currently working through my own
learner rely on parent-child curriculum
I'm not a huge fan of the school system
I think they do a whole lot to dilute
the mental for my children if you lost
everything any day what you got tomorrow
what is intellectual property she can
take your possessions but they can't
take your mind and daddy had an
emergency in his house and you needed to
save my life what going to use laughs
right - why because has less room if you
have guns in your house I've seen them
before
a lot of shootings take place after
night when it takes place after dark so
essentially what she has to do she has
to locate her round I'm sorry her
magazine in her weapon chamber both Wow
answering questions from my curriculum
three two one go who is he doing what do
a summer been lying the dha'fi and her
Dom was saying all have in common the
Western banks are you a buyer or seller
good job Wow oh that's tight I do
believe that gun education is if you're
gonna have a gun like you have to teach
your kids how to use it properly and
safety you know the issue with the way
that he teaches his kids if there's
there's no diversity in his education
you know what I mean like there's no
counter thought so it's more like in
doctrine rather than exactly yeah yeah
that's true and that's like my biggest
issue with the way that he's teaching
his kids because it's also teaching them
to be very very very very very
close-minded and that's a big problem
there's a reason why I like I think a
lot of the times people [ __ ] on the
education that kids get in school which
money you like is very flawed but the
difference is is that there's options
and there's choices and that's really
what school does for you it gives you
all this stuff to pick from so you could
really pick a stead of this which is
very in doctrine ated and this like this
is the way of life this is how you think
that's it he's like I'll streamline it
for them yeah instead of letting them
kind of figure it out on earth but I
feel like the school system kind of has
it like that in the elementary it's fed
to you intermediate you're kind of
giving a little bit more information in
and then high school and college it's
compared to to this though I think like
it is I think absolutely not prep to
this they let you make up your mind if
you're a second Amendment supporter or
not this it's like you're gonna love
guns when I what I see I see I've got a
lot of I mean at least in California
it's very like just anti-gun if you like
our pro-gun then you're like that's
wrong
well when I went to school they taught
they taught us to history my social
studies
how it became part of like the
Constitution so it you had a chance like
every step of the way but that all
depends on a teacher so it sounds like
you had like a good spectrum of teacher
that's true if you like a lot of some
schools are very liberal some schools
are more like diversified it just
depends I guess on what teacher you get
yeah I remember in third or fourth grade
they were teaching us the difference
between Democrats and Republican and all
the different things that Republicans
are for and all the different things
that you know Democrats are for and then
majority of the students chose Democrat
and then I chose Republican because I
was Christian at the time I grew up in a
church and another thing is I loved guns
so I didn't know anything else about
abortion or whatever right but I mean
most kids don't but when I chose that I
feel like I was being forced to become
left and then I joined them like the
Democrat group because everyone else
eventually at the end of the day the
whole class turned like Democrat
pressured from the teacher and other
students yes I'm in third or fourth
grade you don't know so I think there's
brainwashing everywhere you go mm-hmm
in my high school my history teacher I
had him for two years because I liked
him as a person but he got everyone to
be on the side of communism like he was
like this is why communism is good and
this is why it's like you know it's got
a bad name but it's really good and you
brought in like speakers to speak about
how communism is good and so I full-on
was like dude we've been told a lie
about communism it's so good and we
weren't taught any of the reasons why I
felt like I didn't get enough of why
communism was bad until later when I was
like oh that doesn't make sense because
it's like some people are doing more
work but everyone gets paid equal and
it's like you know there's a lot of
reasons why it works in theory if
everyone's working equally but it I like
that though because in one year you can
go extreme one way in the next year
another teacher can flip you that's true
but then in this one here's only one
source never getting flip
navigating flip that's true I like that
he's teaching the kids alternative
thoughts in education because I feel
like none of the stuff that he's
teaching will be taught at the American
School like system ever they'll never
talk about though never research Gaddafi
or Osama or any of those quote-unquote
terrorists and figure out what their
point was so that we could grow critical
thinking citizens they're just gonna
Oscars like you're immediately trained
to think North Korea Iran all these guys
are our sworn enemies and they should
all die like we're not we're not really
taught vertical speaking is something
that's hugely lacking right in the
public school system I will say that I
mean think about the the Pledge of
Allegiance right we don't have a choice
all of us have to say it in class and
you do it every [ __ ] morning and then
you remember it and then before you know
it you're like Donna died for the
country and it's so [ __ ] weird right
and I think that's the point of being a
citizen though the point is to be
brainwashed brainwashing the difference
every country has its own Allegiance I'm
not against it I feel like in formation
building we need it if we if we don't
have citizens that our diet that are
willing to die for the country another
country that is better at brainwashing
will come over and take over yeah but
that guy he did say in the beginning
these are what I think you need to
survive so like the tools of survival
even if it is you know one train of
thought it's like this is what he thinks
will help his kids like survive in the
world it's pretty militant though the
best survival only think when he was
having the daughter do the splits that
was like a chun-li Street fight that
Bali
oh she's into gymnastics okay I thought
that was put I was holding her ass
[ __ ] spinning a laser on a
father-daughter dance a little
background with Derek his dad was a
Secret Service retiree and then his
grandfather worked at worked in the
sheriff's office and and then Derek
himself he was a 911 dispatcher how do
you get all of these tests loser come
yeah I've seen it he does dude
like he goes around the country he does
does it say what the face tattoos mean
uh he doesn't say just quick notes right
now real quick [ __ ] what's your address
so he does talk about one tattoo on his
forehead says ABC it means adversity
builds character ah stop always be
closing his character reminds me of
Nicolas Cage's character on kick-ass
were yes his daughter and then his
daughters all dope like that I'm all
like oh this kind of feels like that
yeah he takes his kids to the gun range
so they can feel real recoil and like
yeah I mean he's all about that but yeah
he does travel he does do towards [ __ ]
I've seen this guy before
what did you see him uh on Instagram
maybe on the interwebs coming to LA I
saw on his web page I wonder what he
talks about I'm interested nice about
his curriculum he also has like a hole
how to teach her children yeah he has
books for people to buy the curriculum
teacher home yeah he's a very memorable
of course look at his fish